foreign
you guys we're doing another flickers of
fear haven't one done one of these in a
while so I thought I would get back into
it
so as I've probably mentioned a time or
two before or several hundred times
before
um I don't really have any kind of
scientific basis or anything like that
for choosing whatever movies or books
that I'm going to be you know reading
watching reviewing like for this you
know channel for the series
um I essentially what I do is I just
kind of browse around through all of the
horror movies that are on offer on all
of the various streaming services that I
subscribe to or if it's a book then I'll
scroll through my Kindle unlimited stuff
and I just kind of pick whatever looks
interesting at that particular time and
for whatever particular mood that I
happen to be in that day
so when I came across this little film
called isolation while I was scrolling
through the movies on shutter like I
think it just got added like maybe last
month or something like that I basically
just picked it the only reason I picked
it was because it had Essie Davis in it
who horror fans obviously will recognize
from uh the babadook from 2014 and it
also had Sean Harris who was in the
excellent uh 2018 film possum which I
think I reviewed a little while back and
he also played Ian Curtis from Joy
Division in probably one of my favorite
films of all time the 2002 film 24 hour
party people uh which is about the
Manchester music scene of the 70s and
80s and it was directed by uh Michael
winterbottom so yeah so he played Ian
Curtis in that
so the two of them are in it I'm like
all right I'm on board
um now I actually didn't realize until I
was researching this video that
isolation is damn near two decades old
at this point which kind of blew my mind
a little bit it came out it was actually
released direct to DVD like way the [__]
back in 2005 and I'm gonna say like to
its credit I had no idea like while I
was watching it that it was that old
especially because Essie Davis like I
just saw the babadook again like pretty
recently and she doesn't really look
that different in the babadook which was
2014 than she did in this movie which
was 2005 like at least not enough for me
to like notice like a massive age
difference so that's why I think I was
kind of surprised that this is as old as
it was but yeah so it kind of threw me
for a loop a little bit but I it doesn't
really make any difference that it's
2005 like there's nothing in it that
it's like oh the cell phones are old
because it's not like Technology based
so I guess that's why I didn't really
notice but aside from all that so
isolation is actually an Irish film and
it was directed by a guy named Billy
O'Brien this was actually his first uh
the first movie that he directed the
first his feature-length debut and it
actually I believe got best director and
best film uh prizes at that Year's
fantastic Fest like when it came out at
the at that
um now O'Brien actually went on to make
another movie 2016's I am not a serial
killer and that actually has Christopher
Lloyd in it now I haven't seen that but
I watched the trailer and I'm like oh
that looks pretty good too so I mean I
liked this one so I might like get
around to watching that one uh for you
know at some point too
um and you know for a first feature like
isolation is pretty solid I don't think
it's like necessarily anything to like
Rave about or go completely nuts over or
anything like that but it is like a
really good like atmospheric kind of
low-key movie with some really great
acting performances it has like this
really dour like Grim tone to it which I
dug has some like decent Gru it's not
like you know super super gory but it
does have some good effects in it and it
has like kind of a mystery that sort of
keeps you invested like during the
entire run time now it does have um I
mean I kind of feel like the ending like
the payoff is pretty satisfying but it's
pretty predictable like if you know
anything about hormones you kind of know
like what's gonna happen at the end but
I don't think that was to the movie's
detriment
um so to get an idea of like the
ballpark of like what this movie is like
imagine if you know John Carpenter's The
Thing uh and you know alien really
Scott's alien being kind of
agriculturally cross-bred with like a
1970s Eco horror you know what I mean
but without any of the unintentional
hilarity that that last Clause might
apply because you know like I love 70s
Eco horror because that was like a big
thing but some of them were like pretty
cheesy and like over the top and this
one is not really like that but it does
have that similar kind of it does have a
similar kind of structure and a similar
kind of setup to like a 70s Eco horror
but it's played seriously and it's not
cheesy you know what I mean so so that's
kind of like the vibe that it's going
for
I mean the only real beef I have at the
movie uh is the title I don't love the
title I mean because it's like pretty
generic and it doesn't really have all
that much to do with the plot I mean
other than the whole thing taking place
on a real remote Farm like with only a
handful of characters
um I mean the movie could have been
called like any number of other things
that because the thing about it is when
I went looking for this movie like you
know because I wanted to get a backstory
on it like after I'd watched it there's
several other movies that are called
isolation and for a while it took me a
while to find the right one because I
wasn't looking for one from way the [__]
back in 2005 like I said so there's one
that came out in 2017 and for a while I
thought it was that and I'm like no
that's not it and you know so there's a
lot of other movies called that I really
don't like movies that have these
generic titles like that so that's
pretty much the only complaint that I'm
gonna make about it so our nominal main
protagonist I guess because this is kind
of like an ensemble piece there's like
five characters uh so you know the main
protagonist sort of is named Dan and
he's played by John Lynch who I've seen
and like lots of other things now he
owns this Farm where the whole thing
takes place
and it's kind of like you're led to
assume that it's kind of like a failing
operation and it's way out in the
[__] back end Beyond somewhere like
in Ireland
now we learned pretty early on in the
movie that because the farm has been
failing uh that Dan has been taking
money from some kind of shady like
genetic science outfit I'm assuming
they're Shady they are always Shady in
these kind of movies
um so this this outfit is like
experimenting on one of his cows
now for a long time we don't know
exactly like what this experiment
entails like what their end goal is or
anything like that but because this is
obviously a horror movie you know that
whatever the [__] is it's like not gonna
be good
now this suspicion that you have is
confirmed shortly afterward uh during a
visit from the veterinarian whose name
is Orla who's played by Essie Davis now
the veterinarian is like assisting the
main scientist whose name is John who's
played by uh Marcel irres eures I think
he's Romanian I'm sure I'm pronouncing
his last name wrong so I apologize for
that
um and there's kind of like a play they
don't go too much into this but this is
just kind of like a little side thing
but I'm pretty sure that Orla like the
veterinarian is [__] the scientist
but it's like like I said it's not a
subplot or anything like that it's just
kind of like brought up I think it's
also further implied that Dan the farmer
and Orla used to be a thing too because
Dan seems like awfully upset or like too
invested in the fact that orla's new
situation of her like knocking Wellies
with the scientists possibly and you
know and she's kind of like hey that's
none of your business so I thought well
maybe they had a thing before like maybe
that's his ex-wife or something like
that like I said they don't really go
into it and maybe I'm making like way
more of it than the movie did obviously
but it was just something I noticed and
I was like I was interested like why
they didn't do a lot with that like they
just kind of brought it up they didn't
didn't do a lot with it
so anyway so Orla comes out for the
veterinarian visit you know on behalf of
the scientist and she has her hand you
know kind of strategically inserted up
the test cow's cooch there and uh the
presumed baby cow like that's in the
bigger cow uh seems to bite her like
bite her hand which uh you know for
those not super familiar with cows and
their offspring is not generally
something that a little catholic in
utero would be doing I mean that that I
know of
so um Dan is just kind of like what what
do you mean to [__] you it's like
that's that didn't happen maybe you just
like cut your hand or maybe it was like
you know the bones compression or
something like that because it was just
like a like a kind of a crescent shaped
like cut on her hand but Orla is like
yeah maybe so but she's not really sure
because she's kind of more privy to
whatever this experiment is and so she's
starting to wonder if John the main
scientist if his you know still
unrevealed to the audience experiment is
kind of going drastically sideways
spoiler alert it is so meanwhile there's
also kind of like a wild card element
introduced uh into the story in the form
of two Travelers I guess they would call
them so Jamie who's played by Sean
Harris and his girlfriend Mary he's
played by Ruth Nega and they're both
kind of like they don't go a lot into
this either but this is kind of just
like mentioned I guess they're sort of
on the run from Mary's brothers because
they don't like that she's dating a
traveler or I guess they think he's a
bum or something like that so they're
kind of like chasing them or like coming
after them with with the implication
that they'll kick Jamie's ass or kill
him or something like that if they find
him I'm not really sure like I said they
don't go super super into that and I
don't think that like the that they
never show up or they never factor into
the story
so The Travelers have parked their
Caravan or their trailer you know
whatever if I know it's Caravan in the
UK but over here we would probably say
trailer that they've been living in and
they've kind of parked it right on the
periphery of like Dan's land like right
outside of his of his gate now because
the experiment that is going on on Dan's
Farm is supposed to be top secret John
the main scientist he wants these
Travelers like out of there before they
see something they shouldn't see and Dan
the farmer isn't really a big fan of
these random people like being on his
even though they're not technically on
his land they're just like right outside
his gate but they're still like right
there like right at the end of the road
that leads to his farm so he basically
is just like well you guys got to get
out of here so he gives him like a day
to clear out
that night though uh the experimented
upon cow the one with the little calf
that was biting goes into labor
and Dan discovers that he can't
extricate the calf from its mother by
himself because the little [__] is
stuck in there and like I don't know how
accurate this is because I didn't grow
up on a farm or anything like that but
um is it the case that sometimes the
calf does like get stuck in it which I
assume yeah it does happen but uh Dan on
his farm he has like a winch type
situation like I guess just in case like
you know you tie the ropes around the
little calf's legs and like just pull
like with the crank and everything like
that I'm like holy [__] that is [__]
up but uh but yeah so he does that and
he can't still can't get the calf out
like it is really [__] wedged in
there right so he actually is forced
because there's really nobody else
around
um he has to go and get the traveler
Jamie to kind of help out with the
operation now this operation they
eventually do get the little calf out of
there however uh when the calf is born
it's a little bit bitey let's say that
um and when the veterinarian Orla like
gets there she notes that the calf's
teeth are severely malformed so much so
that they look pretty much like fangs
and also the calf is like acting really
weird like they think it's gonna die and
they're probably pretty much the where
we probably need to like put this out of
its misery because there's something
like not right about it now at this
point you might be thinking to yourself
as I was as I was watching this movie
why didn't they call this movie Mad Cow
right like this is going to be a killer
cow movie right I was like so I'm
watching it and I'm like I actually
because the tone of it was so serious I
actually wasn't sure how if how I felt
about the concept of a killer cow movie
like especially like played as straight
as this one seem to be doing up to this
point but as the story unfolded I
actually kind of found myself relieved
that it wasn't called mad cow because
you know come on that would have been a
little bit silly for a movie as you know
serious as this one and there's actually
something a little bit more Insidious
than just like you know a killer cow
type concept going on
um isolation in fact eventually becomes
something like kind of like an infection
style horror more than like a monster
type thing but it does have like a
little bit of like a mad scientist a
little bit of a monster movie thing
going on too but not like a killer cow
type of monster if you know what I mean
so I don't want to spoil too much about
what this experiment involves and like
what the horrible outcomes of it um are
like what exactly went wrong with all of
the wants and genetic engineering that
John was tinkering with and poor
Bessie's womb there but uh suffice it to
say that the five people that are stuck
on this got forsaken Farm are um kind of
been for a pretty bad time
so this movie is actually it was you
know it had a very very gripping
narrative
um had obvious nods to the thing in
particular and I really kind of liked
the more modern serious take on the Eco
horror films in the 1970s because like I
said you know as much as I love those a
lot of them were like super super cheesy
they were like all these kind of like
you know I hate to use this term but
like a lot of like has been actors are
like past their Prime actors like being
in these things like reacting to like
ridiculous you know it just got
ridiculous after a while like night of
the leapis like killer giant bunny
rabbits and [__] like that so I was kind
of afraid that this was gonna go that
route but like expect us to take it
seriously but it doesn't so like don't
worry about that
um now the cast of this is very small I
guess it's basically only five people I
think you only really only ever see one
person like an other scene like a cop or
something
um so and the characters don't get a
hell of a lot of development but there
is like just enough there like just with
little offhand remarks and stuff like
that that there's like you know hints of
like a larger story or like larger
character develop development there so
you do kind of get invested in them as
people as they sort of like try to
figure out what's going on in this farm
and what they're gonna do to stop it
um all the acting obviously is
outstanding you know pretty unsurprising
giving the pedigrees of those involved
this has a lot of really great actors in
it so I mean the story isn't anything
particularly new and like I said the
ending probably won't be you know the
little twist ending or whatever it's not
necessarily A Twist but you know what I
mean like the little gotcha ending
um I don't think that's going to be like
a surprise to anybody with even just
like a passing interest in horror movies
but you know that said uh the entire
movie is really very solidly constructed
and really builds up some great suspense
especially in the long lead up that it
goes into like where you don't know what
exactly the experiment is you know what
I mean like for a really long time and I
think that was a good idea to like kind
of just thread it out really slowly like
that because the whole time I'm just
like what the [__] is going like what
are they doing what am I you know what's
going on so I think that was like a good
idea because it really kind of sucked
you in
um and the third act I will say is
really good very very taut very
absorbing it's you know kind of
action-packed
um and it definitely takes some cues
from uh Alien prob particularly like the
air duct sequence I was getting a little
bit of vibes from that but yeah so it's
really well done in that regard now keep
in mind this movie is not super gory it
looks like a blood bath or anything like
that but it does have a few kind of
grisly more like anatomical or autopsy
type stuff of you know cow insides like
cows being cut open and like autopsied
and stuff and it does have like some
upsetting sequences of cows like having
to be put down with a cattle gun so
there was kind of a scene early on in
the movie which if you're kind of like
an animal lover it might be kind of like
upsetting I know they didn't really do
it but you know what I mean it's it is
kind of upsetting like the way it shot
um so if that sort of thing bothers you
then you know you might want to give it
a pass I'm just saying because this
really does involve cows like a lot so
just just saying
um so as of this recording
uh which is you know April of 2023
isolation is actually streaming on
shutter at least in the United States
not really sure about other countries
and um if you like Eco horror like you
know 70s style Eco horror infection
style horror
um you know then it's definitely like
worth a watch like I said it's not the
best movie ever it's not anything like
that but it's really really solid and
it's really well done good acting good
suspense and I just like you know I had
a good time with it just like a solid
solid you know horror movie and it like
I said if you like any of those genres
if you want to see something that's kind
of like homaging the thing homaging
alien but also like kind of doing its
own thing also in sort of like a rural
Irish setting then you probably will dig
this one so you know check it out and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear hope you guys enjoyed it please
remember to like share subscribe all of
that kind of stuff and comment down
below if you have anything to say if
you've seen this movie or if it sounds
intriguing to you then let me know in
the comments and I'll see you guys again
on the next one bye
[Music]
thank you
don't believe me
[Music]